there's a major major Hillary Clinton
story other than this health situation
which is becoming a bigger and bigger
story that is basically being blacked
out by corporate media corporate media
all over the Hillary collapsing fainting
having an overheated and dehydrated
moment yesterday at a 911 memorial event
but completely ignoring the fact that
the entire basis for the recent
pay-to-play allegations involving the
Clinton Foundation and Hillary Clinton
as Secretary of State the entire basis
of that is a tweet from The Associated
Press that tweet has been deleted
because the Associated Press determined
that it was not a good tweet the tweet
from more than two weeks ago said as you
may remember more than half of those who
met with Clinton as cabinet secretary
gave money to the Clinton Foundation
that is part of the original tweet of
course we looked into this others have
looked into this and it immediately fell
apart but that never mattered the right
the the right wing media machine
continue to repeat pay-to-play more than
half of those who met with hillary
clinton a secretary of state were donors
to the clinton foundation countless
right-wingers and hillary bashers said
look it's The Associated Press they are
serious they are trustworthy we can
depend on what they say well the
Associated Press now says we cannot
depend on what they said they have
deleted the tweet you won't hear that on
the Rush Limbaugh Show let's take a look
at a quote from The Associated Press
this is from John Dennis key is the
Associated Press vice president for
standards saying The Associated Press
today is the leading a two-week-old
tweet about Hillary Clinton's meetings
as cabinet secretary after concluding
the tweet fell short of AP standards by
omitting essential context at the same
time we are revising our practices to
require removal and correction of any AP
tweets found not to meet AP standards
including tweets that contain
information that is incorrect misleading
unclear or could be interpreted as
unfair or having a problem in tone
ladies and gentlemen the tweet has been
retracted why was it bogus to begin with
well the AP analysis focused only on
what are called discretionary meetings
with people who are not part of the US
federal government who are not
representatives or parts of foreign
governments who likely are the majority
of the people that Hillary Clinton met
with as Secretary of State this is like
if you go shopping right and you say uh
okay I bought all my food and then you
report fifty percent of the food i
bought is bad it was rancid i got it at
the local grocery store fifty percent of
the food i got was bad the grocery store
is bad and then it turns out that really
fifty percent of the bananas you bother
bad right fifty percent of the bananas
which make up a tiny little portion of
your total total grocery shopping but
it's never retracted media keeps saying
don't go to that grocery store because
fifty percent of all the food that Joe
bot is bad when the reality is that it's
fifty percent of the bananas that's the
analogy for what happened here the
allegation is fifty percent of the
discretionary meetings that Hillary
Clinton had were with individuals who at
some point donated to the Clinton
Foundation and I'm gonna be very very
upfront with you here uh Melinda Gates
is someone that Hillary Clinton met with
who donated to the Clinton Foundation
Melinda Gates is one of the most
prominent philanthropists in the u.s. if
not the world at this point along with
her husband Bill Gates is it really that
shocking or disturbing that she had a
meeting with Hillary Clinton and also
was a donor to the Clinton Foundation it
sort of makes perfect sense when you
look at a lot of the individual names
here so you know I am no Hillary Clinton
cheerleader she is far more conservative
than I am I have serious serious
concerns about her Hawk ish policies and
ideas on some issues related to the
Middle East I believe we should have a
fifteen dollar minimum-wage wage instead
of 12 is she has said this is not about
me saying I love all of Hillary
Clinton's
policies this is about the fact that
there is a total blackout on the phone
on the reality that the tweet on which
much of this controversy was based has
been deleted and retracted because the
source the AP said it does not meet our
standards period I don't know if you're
going to hear that later today on any
right-wing media or even corporate media
will take a break i'm on twitter at d
pakman